hikaru congratulations on an incredible
performance
you knew you were going to win this
thing pretty much uh in the middle of
today
but to not lose a single game you won in
paris twice and you also won st louis
that same 2018 year
have you gone through
a tournament
with any of these ones and not lose any
games whatsoever yeah i mean i i don't
think so i think it's pretty rare and
rapid and blitz certainly did not lose
any games i know in those events i did
lose some games
i think i think paris i i actually came
very close to
to not losing but you know it happened i
lost this this game to magnus but anyway
um yeah it was a good result though to
put it mildly wow abs has a great result
coming in first any
you were invited to the tour you decided
to decline playing this year
any regrets that maybe you could have
played and uh done some real damage
uh no
no regrets at all uh i said it before i
mean i i stream most time it's what i do
primarily these days uh so not
regretting it at all and i mean i i have
other other big events coming up so uh
i'm looking forward to everything else
why did you think you were so successful
in this particular event a lot of
players have been playing i've been
warmed up you had mentioned at the
opening ceremony you're really impressed
by wesley how he's been able to manage
both online and playing as well
over the board
why did this specially work out all so
well for you i mean i think it's pretty
simple i'm a bit of an enigma because uh
obviously i've been streaming a lot you
know i of course primarily is trust that
i'm streaming um
but i think the fact that i've been
streaming so much most people don't
really know whether i'm studying chess
not studying chess how serious i am or
not serious um and so i think no one's
really sure what to expect um
and then in this event certainly i i
just i thought i played very well and i
think the main reason for that is
because as i've said before i consider
myself a streamer first chess player
second and i feel absolutely zero
pressure um you know maybe towards the
end i was a little bit unhappy because
uh of course this plus six corn blitz uh
i lost something like 16 points and you
know magnus made some ridiculous tweet
about it but you know over overall i
would say that uh
i would i would say that um you know
it's it it was just the fact that i was
relaxed throughout and just just very
chill i mean it didn't matter if i won
or lost and i would also say the other
thing is if i look back i'm probably the
player who shows the most emotional over
the board and i don't know but i feel
like i wasn't shaking my head until
maybe the game against
liam today and
i think that says a lot as well why were
you shaking your head in his last name
uh it wasn't so much the result because
the draw was fine but it's just that
liam blundered this pawn on b2 and i
thought i would have winning chances but
uh he he actually played really well on
the blitz and he defended extremely well
in the game after he blundered this pawn
and i just didn't have chances to win so
breaking news for me what was the
ridiculous tweet by magnus oh it was
something where he's making a joke about
how i lost 16 points he's number one in
blitz congrats to world number two rated
rapid and blitz player gm hikaru for
winning the saint louis wrapping and
blitz with dominating unbeaten
performance iron congrats to number two
nice all right well
nothing will
prevent us from
respecting and being completely
impressed by what you did here not
losing a single game against this field
is extraordinary that's an incredible
result the way you did it acted with
class as well great play congratulations
on your title thank you maurice uh
congratulations absolutely hikaru but
you also mentioned you have big events
coming up uh do tell what big events are
they oh
well i mean i think i'll be back here in
september to play the 960 but before
that uh next week i'm going to be doing
an event in detroit i'm sort of
in the vein of doing a simul some irl
chess similar to what i've done uh with
with coffee chess in in la big shout out
to you know mike and everybody who who's
out there um but i'll be playing at the
inner city kids it's a event organized
by detroit chess club and detroit young
thinkers group gonna be in a park big
event next saturday and all that stuff
will be on twitch and youtube so really
looking forward to it then as i said 960
and then maybe maybe after that some
classical but but who knows
wow wow
big event classical well keep up the
fine work and
godspeed wonderful dueling impressed
here hicaro an amazing result
congratulations
just jaw dropping performance unbeaten
yeah i think that's just so
it's so difficult to achieve to go
defeated it really really really is yeah
i was going to say one other thing also
just one last thing is that like so when
you come into an event normally there's
one primary goal which is to win the
event that's obviously your first goal
very rarely do you end up in a situation
where you can potentially have
additional goals and so like for me
coming into this final day the first
thing was make sure i lock the
tournament which i think was pretty
clear from about round four but then the
second thing is like there's a second
one which is try to keep the number one
ranking try try to win some games at the
end which is why i started really
opening it up in the last like three to
four games and there's a third one to
not lose any games and i mean i
accomplished one of those two additional
goals so overall i mean it's it's just
really hard to complain and just i just
enjoyed it and it was fun being back in
st louis and i'm sure i'll be back again
soon speaking of additional goals uh
though hikaru because also not only did
you win the rapid but you also won the
blitz
as well
was that also an additional goal when
you played with uh liam
i
not really although i have to say i was
only a half point ahead so i kind of
knew that he would want to try and win
that game i think i mean who knows if
i'd play the berlin if he would have
made a draw or not but i assumed he
wanted to win because he won that game
he would have the best overall scorer um
so i was looking forward to fighting
game i think he played extraordinarily
well i think uh as i said the other day
i think a lot of players are underrated
but liam is someone who kind of i think
has flown under the radar and blitz and
he had a great great great event in the
blitz portion yes he did indeed
thank you vicar and congratulations
again certainly leon liam showing that
he's an excellent blitz player